[Musique]
quelle que soit son activité pour se
rendre au boulot jusqu'au 11 mai
prochain il est essentiel d'avoir avec
soi une attestation de déplacement une
attestation qui en théorie vous empêche
de vous faire arrêter par la police
sauf dans ce cas cette histoire qui se
déroule en gironde est à peine croyable
trois cambrioleurs qui avaient planifié
de se rendre dans une cave à vin pour
dérober la caisse se sont fait attraper
très rapidement en effet le 24 avril les
trois hommes se rendent sur place et
pendant que le premier détourne
l'attention du vendeur les deux autres
se rendent dans une pièce annexe pour
dérober la caisse pas de chance elle ne
contient que 40 euros
très vite les trois hommes se font
surprendre par le vendeur et décide de
prendre la fuite lors butin en poche le
propriétaire porte plainte
l enquête pour les retrouver n'aura pas
été très difficile étant donné que l'un
des trois cambrioleurs a fait tomber
dans la boutique son attestation de
sortie avec son adresse dessus le soir
même la police se rend sur place et on
est allé avec les trois cambrioleurs
tout ça pour 40 euros comme quoi le
karma existe vraiment ça a été le petit
l'histoire extraordinaire
voilà je lis ça c'était exceptionnel
cette histoire m'a donné envie de revoir
le top 5 des pires voleur de l'histoire
voilà pour vous faire un kiff en
cinquième position des deux cambrioleurs
pas très doué qui essaient d'entrer par
effraction dans un magasin en cassant la
vitrine à coups de brique mais
malheureusement regarder
[Musique]
ça y est le numéro quatre
les pires cambrioleurs regarder on a un
mec qu'a voulu braquer un magasin mais
il a du mal à gérer son stress
regardez
[Musique]
où
on a démontré aujourd'hui en 3d pire
cambrioleurs on a on a six garçons il a
eu la bonne idée d'entrée par le toit
d'un magasin mais il n'a visiblement pas
penser à comment sortir ces problèmes il
a pu rentrer les choses on peut pas un
voleur s'apprête à escalader un magasin
d'alcool on s'y introduire
or le problème il est bourré briscards
comme après plusieurs heures d'efforts
l'homme rejoint le toit
à l'intérieur c'est morceau de toit
commencent à tomber
ce qu'il pensait être une entrée facile
porte s'est avérée compliquée
mais en sortant il a rencontré un autre
problème la loi est en verre blindé
[Musique]
l'homme cidh alors ressortir à où il est
entré par l'ustr race mais il a l'air
encore bien bourré
[Musique]
je sais pour une cigarette et d'attendre
la police il arrive quelques minutes
plus tard on lui demande de s'allonger
sur le sol c'est génial
voilà c'est les pires cambrioleurs aller
au prince 0,2 à double entrée alors je
vais vous montrer cette vidéo les chiens
ou l'a vu des mecs qui veulent voler une
télé un écran plasma exceptionnel ils
sont numéro de regarder
[Musique]
allez
à mon avis alors qui les a toujours pas
la télé papa nous regarde et on les
embrassades bravo à l'échelle et en
numéro 1 pour moi le champion des
cambrioleurs c'est bien sûr ce gars qui
sait prendre la main dans le sac en
train de voler dans une voiture ça
c'était y'a pas longtemps mais ce génie
avec son sac à dos on dirait qu'il va
camper en direct qui part en randonnée
mais regardez lui il est génial voilà on
revoit s'était lâché pendant le conflit
que sa voix de voitures là non c'est
votre voiture
oui pourquoi pas je demande parce que je
ne sais pas si vous êtes sur wii ils
sont certes autonomie il devrait
récupérer son portable
c'est la vôtre ou pas oui c'est parce
alors été ouverte
ça vous ça bien sûr il est tombé par
terre ne leur donnez moi le portable pas
compris alors ils voient tous d'aller et
il m'a dit ah bah c'est bizarre et des
dieux ce que vous êtes entraîneur de
volley mais non seulement pas
aujourd'hui j'ai rien mais c'est vrai
que c'est vrai faire appeler les flics
au rang des savoirs famille c'est sûr
mais oui mais c'est justement j'ai d'une
troupe et toi tu ahmadis une voiture
volée ne vous inquiétez pas le monsieur
est vraiment pour toi il est sympa le
vainqueur reçoit avec reebok dans la
voiture vous êtes déjà fait cambrioler
vous qu'est ce qu'il ya déjà quelqu'un
qui s'est fait cambrioler sa droite
castaldi sûrement oui mais moi oui aux
yeux et aux yeux non ils ont ils ont il
se rend triste ils ont volé toutes les
voitures et moi je me rends la maison
tout le web et wati voiture lui la fin
attention voilà exactement
et en fait ils sont rentrés pendant la
nuit et le matin je me suis réveillée et
j'ai dit mais c'est bizarre je vois fier
à des papiers à l'eau partout il y avait
toutes les clefs ils sont partis que les
voitures est une aubaine pour le coup
ah oui c'est vrai c'est dur ils sont
partis toutes les voitures
ouais mais là ils sont partis mais naïma
doit nous faire la même histoire ils
sont partis tous les deux jours et
beaucoup
tout est trop fort ils ont tout pris et
j'ai vu ma tâche et il a même oublié
bizarre gilles verdez pour vous abonner
quelque chose ou est ce qu'on vous a
déjà récemment récemment en fait pendant
que j'avais pas que j'étais à l'émission
ils ont tout cassé comme il trouvait pas
grand chose ils ont tout cassé
alors je veux dire c'est un jour il y
avait pas bernard montiel dans
l'émission je peux en fille était pas là
oui mais méfiez vous